[Musique]
Je pense donc que c'est très innovant
juste repenser les choses
essayer et j'étais entier
tout l'hôtel est surpris
il est complet il y a tellement d'invités là-bas
qui viennent en plus à cause de ça et c'est
magnifique et je l'ai toujours
Je n'ai jamais vécu que tu le fasses comme ça
[Musique]
donc l'initiative des concerts aux fenêtres
était l'un pour nous en tout premier lieu
opportunité pour les artistes et surtout
une autre possibilité pour la culture
réussir à effectuer
donc vraiment l'affaire d'aujourd'hui
Beaucoup ont rompu demain
l'existence en dépendait nous pensons aussi
que la vitrine des concerts un peu loin
vous aider à revenir
va au-delà de la normalité de la
contacts entre personnes
revient à nouveau et celui-là un
peu loin la peur que le refrain sans
délai de prescription quasi qu'ici
est pris et celui-là encore
se rassemble et c'est bien aussi et
c'est sympa de sortir
[Applaudissements]